so
we can we get deeper into that about
inflation is a term that we've been
conditioned
to think today is just something normal
the prices just go up and then
uh it's pertinent to a healthy economy
but it's actually if you look at it from
real first principles it is just
theft integrated into the money it's a
technology backdoor there's another way
to think about it
you wouldn't buy a cell phone knowing
that someone could siphon your data off
your private calls and sell it into the
market
now i know we do that with a lot of
social media stuff today and that's
something else we can get into but
you wouldn't do it willingly right you
wouldn't you'd prefer that your cell
phone and your data
was monetized by you or if you're gonna
sell it you would be able to selectively
sell it inflation is that it's similar
it's a tech
backdoor so it's a
money that only a few people can siphon
value off of surreptitiously
typically slowly but eventually as we've
seen throughout history that
slowly builds up into a rapidly and then
um causes the monetary system to
collapse
do you think there's a benefit to
inflation possibly so
so when you have perfect information
perhaps you
you don't need inflation perhaps it is
purely theft but i think of inflation as
like the snooze button on the alarm
like you just so if you have a hard
standard
you better wake up when the alarm rings
but
you know all of us kind of like probably
shouldn't but
use the snooze button he's like okay
well five more minutes or ten more
minutes
and then you're saying there's naturally
a slippery slope where you
uh it becomes a drug that you fall in
love with in your abuse
but nevertheless the usefulness of the
snooze button
is that you don't know how you'll be
actually feeling when the alarm
rings you might be able to ready to pop
up it might be
like you really need those few more
minutes like to psychologically get
yourself out of bed
listen now this metaphor is just not
working at all but no no
do you think there's a use to uh to
inflation sometimes from
like an economics perspective i think
the drug metaphor is a little more apt
in that inflation does provide an
immediately
stimulative effect when used
early on so but what it's doing is it's
again we talk about the balance between
incentives and disincentives right that
being necessary for a system to pro to
function properly
if with inflation you're essentially
giving
the people that can print money a way to
dampen the disincentives they face
so it destroys feedback loops
i guess you might say and another way to
look at this
is when you so using inflation using
monet
quantitative easing you can decrease
short-term volatility in the marketplace
so the market is basically this
idea this form of free exchange that's
trying to zero in on the best ideas
and the ideas are those that are most
fit to reality to satisfying the most
wants
it's going to overshoot it's going to
undershoot you have these little
business cycles
but when it's under shooting and you and
you're experiencing
a business recession in a capitalist
environment the market needs to clear
that mal investment that misallocation
of capital that means someone made a bet
on a certain idea that it would satisfy
wants in a particular way
and that bet did not pan out if you then
paper over the losses
that business is creating you're now
delaying
and exacerbating the volatility that
that idea created
so this is kind of a tillabian concept
where
you can dampen short run volatility but
volatility is
truth volatility is us matching
our ideas to reality right we're
constantly again overshooting and
undershooting so if you delay
volatility you're just amplifying it and
exacerbating it in the long
run and that's what central bank is
doing the central bank mandate is
low unemployment and
low and expected inflation basically
and so they're trying to achieve
economic growth
in a stable way quote unquote stable way
this is their ostensible purpose
and that's just not possible growth is
an inherently unstable process
you